41 muertos es el balance casi final de
la explosión de gas metáneo que ocurrió
ayer por la noche en una mina de Carbón
el norte de Turquía en la costa del mar
Negro a unos cientos de kilómetros de
Estambul son 41 muertos a los que se
suman 58 supervivientes 11 de los cuales
están ahora mismo según el Ministerio de
interior de Turquía hospitalizados
algunos de los cuales son están en
estado muy grave el presidente turcos
recepto ahí Perdón ha visitado este
mediodía el sitio donde ocurrió la
explosión la mina donde ocurrió la
explosión y ha explicado que el gobierno
Turco liderará una investigación para
esclarecer lo que ocurrió se habla sobre
todo que lo más probable es que el
sistema de ventilación de la mina
fallase y a 300 metros de profundidad
donde estaban trabajando gran parte de
los mineros que estaban dentro de la
mina se habla que había dentro de la
mina 110 Mineros
o se acumuló gas metano que después se
acabó explotando erdogan ha estado
visitando las familias de Los afectados
y a los supervivientes y ha explicado
que Turquía era todo lo posible para
intentar solucionar y que no ocurra más
a dicho el presidente Turco una tragedia
como este que es muy común más de lo que
debería en Turquía se habla de que en la
última década más de mil personas han
muerto más de mil mineros han muerto por
accidentes de este tipo el último y el
más grande de todos fue en 2014 cuando
en la provincia de soma 300 mineros
murieron en una explosión también dentro
de una mina